[Music]
all right welcome everyone to the 7:30
class and this is a password we show
famous player games really nice games so
this is a game between lad Amir Bhagat
off and against Edouard GU fault and
it's a King's Indian game and if you
don't know about GU fathi he loved his
King's Indians and dragon with the
bishop on g7 positions so he really
believed in these positions and he
always played it and he played against
some of the best players in the world
this is USSR championship game so played
in 1973 so by a slight unusual move
order we basically get a Kings Indian
defense f3 setup
what is this setup called here see a
mesh setup okay semi setup so this gives
white a very strong center but it does
create a little bit of weaknesses on the
dark squares here okay so but in return
it gets a very strong control of the
center and normally white wants to go
Bishop e3 Queen d2 long castle and just
attack so I Castle there should be three
Knight to c6 one of the many options
here by the way the cost part of
garriga's product played these positions
many times is a very good game against
Anatoly Karpov that he warned think it
was a t5 so there's a lot of you know
this have tricky positions to play you
may think oh I just put the center and
it's gonna be easy to play but no it's
very complex and and this game is gonna
be no difference it's just very
complicated game it's it's hard to play
this positions so if you're trying to
figure out what to do against Kings
Indian same issues is a very good
probably it's a good setup but it's it's
very complicated to play I've tried
playing a couple of times and it's it's
there's so many things black can do so
96 is one of them it's now black is
considering the move e5 and putting the
knight on d4 even so Knight g2 is that's
why I played because now if you play e5
you normally don't want to allow black
to come in here and here you can just
take twice but let's say you play this
move right you might be wondering why am
I saying that but now I go here you take
right take sting you may think oh I'm up
a pawn I run into a big problem now 94
hitting your queen takes rook e8 and
then you lose your queen
so in general like even if I didn't have
this right I probably have a good
compensation here just because of that
Bishop just even if I play something
like Knight h5 hitting the Queen Queen
returns here something like a 5 this is
good enough compensation to play okay so
that's why we see a move Knight G - I
actually grew up when I grew up and I
was just starting out I actually played
the same ish and always liked it but
later on in my career after I became a
grandmaster and used to play it it's
it's a pretty pretty challenging
so rook b8 now played
Queen d2 protecting it a six
I deal of course of repeat a-sixes try
to get a contra play would be five in a
bush page six White says you know I'm
going to allow you to play b5 I'm gonna
concentrate on the attack which is a
typical thing they do here they try to
play after they exchange the bishops
they try to go for h4 h5 ideas and try
to get a a pressure b5 plate h4 ePHI
block is trying to get a contra plate so
again if you analyze this game which was
played in 1973 with a modern computer of
course you might find that the White was
doing really well at some point okay
but that's not the really the point the
point is to understand how the ideas
work and if you want to play this as
block you will see what GU Phil did in
this game and also you know up for white
what the Grandmaster bugger off to okay
again this is no really a big point in
analyzing the the very old games with
the modern computers because yeah you're
gonna find a lot of even a lot of the
masterpieces you know you're gonna just
refute them because you know but back
then there were no engine so level of
defense was different so now take take
h5 idea is to play you know open up the
position at some point maybe even to
play h6
and if you take he wants to play typical
move g4 force you back check and I mean
this is very dangerous I mean this is
very very dangerous things could happen
now after g5 so g5 or actually this
probably just wings okay
you have to be very careful so King h8
King gate shade and he wants to if white
captured he wants to take FGM and he
wants to you know that he doesn't want
to allow white to play Queen h6 I mean
by looking at the position it feels like
why should be much better here because
if you have to make a move like King h8
it looks very very dangerous
so by the way 95 plate trying to
exchange the Knights takes opening up
the H file and Queen h6 now the idea is
Knight takes f6 and Queen h7 mate that
is the idea
Knight takes f6 Queen a soulmate equals
95 blocking the H file
because the threat was already very
strong night xf6
with the idea queen h7 mate so he just
tries to block it
white cost g4 just trying to move this
night away and just just trying to
checkmate very straightforward plan
rook takes b2 he is ignoring the fact
the knight is hanging so capturing rook
takes b2 now the rook is very active but
you down a piece now g5 this is now a
positional move that locks in the
position and also it shuts down the
Queen so this is a very good point he
had when he played the move g5 without
this move I think it's a big big trouble
and now things are hanging things are
very loose here f.3d for King is in the
middle White has a couple of pawns if we
do a pawn count 1 2 3 4 5 vs. 7 so
there's 2 pounds already that block has
rook is now active on f3 f file it'll
come b2 such very interesting very
interesting position and in good
compensation now Rob g1 very direct
approach in this game by Grandmaster
back it off Rock Jiwon now he is
threatening to take the pawn on g5 and
continue with his threat of just try to
mate Queen g7 now what do you think
black should do here
g4 of course pushing the pawn that
prevents rook g5 and he wants to keep
the G file closed not to mention the
possibility of the Queen coming into h4
as well very strong idea G for long
castle look at that
King is exposed but he runs away with
this idea and attacking the rook always
remember it don't forget this idea
because y can always do this long castle
and attack the rook rook a too
and now Knight f4 yes sacrificing the
night blocking the air file trying to
get the pawn on c4 or night EXA for now
he is hoping that you know he will have
96 I mean the white king looks extremely
weak here but still there is a threat
out there that you have to deal with
very strong threat not just six but by
now it's feels pretty clear that white
is doing you know white is a pretty big
trouble here the knight is causing
problem in that case what you should do
to get rid of the problem eliminate it
right takes that problem is gone and now
c3 now he wants to play night before and
simply mate and why doesn't have enough
time
94 and made his coming Bishop c4
activating the bishop and putting
pressure on the rock rope 83 still with
the idea of night before and just made
takes night before material advantages
on a white side but the threat is very
powerful simply a maid palm on see 3 is
doing a good job covering up the dark
squares and night on before is covering
the C 2 square and thread is very
powerful
just to make well not much to do right
the only way to stop it is to go here
and now here of course you have c2 king
b2 you take I think but it's this Luke
is hanging and the attack is kind of
stalled here and there's still some
weaknesses around the king so it's not
suppressed so here's goofin comes up
with a very interesting idea to
sacrifice his bishop but to get his
queen into the game so of course back it
off takes what else to do
and now Queen b8 Queen f6 you get made
it so you don't have time to do this
because you're actually unfortunately
get rekt made it first so you can get
that in but it has to be done with the
check
93 perfect yes because now if it takes
you have a queen be a check so if it
takes check check and mate okay if you
go skiing see - then we can do it check
track okay so this Bishop is 693 is a
very strong idea
Queen f7 only move Queen f7 only move
trying to stay in the game basically
that is the only idea try to stay in the
game now
this is where you have to find a mate
otherwise you will lose Queen b8 correct
this should be three well if I working
with you I think you will win with check
check if I go back check and mate right
so he goes here now
rook takes bishop
and now if you go to pee to eat does
King take cd3 and he's stopping
everything okay so we got checked this
way
so he took if he goes back then I think
we can just use this idea right check
check
we're not losing the night here the good
news this and something like this pick
up that Queen win the game and if it
goes here now night before check if you
move the way it take check mate
so he has to he has to take so he did
now
93 then he's asking c3 actually he
doesn't want to lose the c-pawn 92 maybe
better 92 I have some escape squares
only three you know of course 95 now if
he goes here let's just try to
understand here mate here mate
here Queen before check will be 2 main
so has to go here now
now this III is taken it to it is all
taken let's look just look look at the
whole board okay don't be stuck on one
area look at the whole board he keeps
trying to go to d3 you don't want him to
go to the tray it's hard to make him
there try to see if you can push it to
go to b3 let's say perfect now if he
goes to be one ego could be to mate so
he has to go here couldn't be to check
he goes here it's mate if he goes here
now what do you do
wait perfect got it that is the very
famous game
Bagheera of goo felt let's go back and
this is a tough game to understand so
we're gonna go back and go very slowly
and I want you to find all the moves
okay bye black go 33 moves total g6 just
like remember unusual move order c4
now
perfect
so we have a semi system right Samish
system many different ways to play here
you can play c5 you can play e5 you have
many different things you can do here
but what's the what's the idea that he
did here 96
now look Beatrice Claudia remember to
play a 6 mb 5 Queen d2 the point of
rookie b8 is to play a 6 and then look
for that possibility with b5 so how are
we gonna do it perfect
now what did you be fart rating before
h4
he went for the break on the center okay
page five again if you take night h5g
for it's very annoying so here where he
played a tough move you know unusual
looking move here yes I'm pretty sure it
copy white is better here but it has to
play very very precisely maybe she takes
b6 or something it feels like place my
intuition tells me that this should be
better for Y you know but again it's
it's very hard you know because you know
black player it just has lots of
experience experience counts in this
position so it placed 95 now
context takes and why probably thought
he's gonna have this nice and easy win
here you know with a straightforward
attack but another very tough move to
find who would have played this move in
a real tournament game guys you think
you would play this move because it
looks bad g4 is coming you know it looks
really bad really difficult
now
perfect rook takes b2 pawn takes Knight
g5
rook Jiwon trying to win the pawn on c5
or even Queen g5 and now we tossed upon
if it takes Queen h4 is very dangerous
you know you might not survive this you
know probably it made it so he goes long
castle rook takes a 294 very dangerous
to open up to F foul so he gives the
night no context first Knight takes and
now the threat is 96
so what did he play the rook takes F for
another sacrifice he sacrificed the
piece then I sacrifice the rook and he's
gonna go on and on until the end of the
game he takes now you wanna try to put
that meeting net right and plus he's
threatening bishop takes here c3
takes
all the squares are taken and rook a one
mate is coming to get the mate okay
King bee one perfect double exclamation
mark okay perfect now continue not Queen
a b8 because you get mated another
subtle sacrifice if he takes he just
gets made it with cream be a queen bee -
so he goes here try to mix it more
difficult now
check if King see to that runs into
queen bee - so he has to go here takes
check
if can see one we just do it this way
okay kingi to King III Queenie - who's
the Queen Queen C for night before Tex
check
truck
checkmate
and if it goes yeah so you have to look
at this idea check actually he resigned
after this well this is a very important
move Queenie - if it goes back to C 1
then we have could be to mate and if
King B 3 so again very famous game of
bugger off versus GU felt ok so this is
from 1973 very very important game in a
king's indian Samish ok so there are
other openings that you can play of
course as white here you know you don't
have to play f3 f3 gives white a big
center and possibilities to attack but
it's very back and forth it's a back and
forth game ok as you can see in this one
it was a race and it came down to who
was faster and it happened to be the
black was faster in this particular
position ok all right now I want to
bring a one example to you from my game
okay and it's it's about an end game I
had so this was played in a protest
League basically we play this on
yesterday so I'm playing with a white
pieces I'm white against International
Master Patel and ok baby should be 4 and
so it's black to move so let's put this
Bishop here so let's discuss this
endgame little bit ok to try to
understand first of all I want to give
you a couple of minutes to think so you
can give me a definite definite
evaluation so definite evaluation of
this position like is the winning or is
it
material yes but if if we always go by
material in end games it's not so easy
right because it's not always so so
first give it a little thought okay
think a little bit and then you can tell
me what do you think is this a definite
win or this is maybe not a definite win
should be winning okay most people think
it's winning all right question is now
how about a plan right what would be the
plan to win this yes that's a good plan
you have to be a little bit careful his
King not getting to here you know
because if you just put the parts H 3 or
3 then G 2 is weak and if it gets in
with the king
if it if again if we trade the pawns
it's gonna be a draw Bishop versus nice
so I'll tell you what happened in our
game so I did this he did this it's a
win but it's not an easy one okay so you
went here I went here you will hear I
got to this position
sort of
and
and the problem I was having here again
this was a 15 minute game and in a real
game like in a real tournament game I
probably can't think and maybe play g4
without worrying about anything I'd
probably win this so let's think here I
want to give you a little bit of time to
think because I don't think you know if
you just move the King you'll be able to
win because this will be met by King f5
which happened in a game III won the
game but I want you to think a little
bit and see what would be the simplest
way to win this position which moves are
important to play here to achieve the
winning position do you want to allow
him to play G for h4 you don't want to
allow this it's like you have to balance
this yeah b5 yes so maybe he goes
somewhere here just try to think h4
maybe he even takes and then you have to
worry about getting this back in the
original position what can we do here
huh the main idea here what can we do
mmm-hmm chief all right so of course you
always worried about the exchange of the
pawns and now let's say he sits right
the rookie's doing a great job here
cutting the king you know so that's good
now which piece you think you can
improve a little bit more to the maximum
of it perfect no egos here by the way he
cannot play the move fi because through
p6 check okay so he has to go here now
perfect now f5 you just gonna take so he
waits pay attention you don't want to
give up the pawn he sits and now what is
your breakthrough method here all right
this I like this idea that's good now
because the bishop that moves away and
now what is the idea here to get his
rule you want to get your rook in I will
move him him away from the pawn
there you go perfect
yes now you want to go rook GA check if
he sits check and you get in here check
take the pawns okay so he can't do that
and if he doesn't want you to do that he
has to go here and now I will play King
f5 covering that square he sits don't
blunder the rock memory check if he goes
here now
beautiful takes takes and you win this
okay
and if it goes to the back rank what do
you do
g6 if it goes here you have the mate ups
again don't blunder the rock so stay
with the plan right and you take so
that's the winning method okay so
basically that's what you need to do
here before opponent can play h4 even
you know you fix the position with this
move okay g4 is the right idea to fix
because hitting f5 I end up winning with
a different method you know I again it
was much longer journey you know but I
end up winning it anywhere I brought my
king to have seven so but again it was
just a much much longer idea which you
don't need to worry about you just just
just play the move three four fix the
structure so his king is in the box the
pawn on g4 he keeps the king in a box
from where he cannot escape from okay
and then you will win by using the and
if h4 same idea deflect if he stays on
this diagonal you can just go here
or actually
just start with this I get the kink only
six
since
I get behind it 13 checking of seven if
you go here now you got fire check
he goes here again you will go look up
seven I take if you go here threating
mate thank you very much
got it okay very good now at the end we
will do a couple of important studies
for you okay now another tough position
here we have the reason I say tough
because here you have to find the
difficult ideas to win because there are
no pawns on the board that means if the
Queen's come off the board it's an
immediate draw so here you have to find
the right sequence of moves to set up
the ideal position and then go for the
the right idea to win quite a tough one
here quite a tough one white to play and
win but the good news is 19 Queen they
work together very well to set up mating
nets and mating mechanisms okay
mating Nets and mechanisms so we check
we get the same position right and now
now he's starting to check on g6 so the
same idea you get to the right position
and now you need to find a square to
hide the King King the two and you pass
the turn to him now let's look at these
options King cannot move
you cannot go here you take you cannot
go here here you take here you take here
you take here you made okay here you
made here you made so let it go see now
he occupies the only square his king can
go to and then so let's go back and do
this one more time slowly go ahead okay
continue check again
he goes here because if he goes here she
gets made it via check mate and mate
so it goes here now what do you do check
check
check mate
and if he King has no scores any other
place he goes you have weight okay so
the quiet move idea is very important
when you're trying to do studies always
look to to get a position to improve and
then a quiet move the souq Salonga idea
works in many many positions in a real
games as well too you have to look at
this ideas so you can see alright very
good so we studied the game by gear of
cool bloom fit I recommend you look at
this game one more time at home you can
find this game by just googling it from
1973 and go as slow as you like and with
it some good studies so thank everyone
for coming for the classes and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]